look back compared to what other
generations have gone through other
periods of crisis in this country 53
days is nothing we've dealt with really
intense terrible situations for a long
time in the past but it feels very long
and it's very stressful and that's
that's across the board you know you
have families that haven't had a
paycheck come in in a couple of months
and meanwhile the bills keep coming in
that's tremendous economic anxiety and
insecurity and by the way it's exactly
right when do I go back to work we do I
get another paycheck and that's a
pressure that people feel in the
household even the good part of it well
my family's together I have all my three
girls in my case with me and that's nice
and that's good news but you put even
the family together and you lock them up
cabin fever and you everybody has their
own stress that they're dealing with and
everyone's trying to figure out their
life and they were all together in this
intense period even that is stressful I
feel it in my own household my daughters
are getting tired of my jokes
believe it or not how that can happen I
have no idea but somehow they they
managed to do that you even have trouble
now picking a movie at night because the
rule is if you pick a bad movie then you
are on movie probation you don't get to
pick the next movie everybody is on
movie probation in my house now so
that's a problem even the dog captain is
out of sorts and relating to stress
maybe there's too many people in the
house and he's having trouble adjusting
captain doesn't like the boyfriend I
said I like the boyfriend so there's
nothing that I said but all sorts of
tension that people are living with real
tension and then just the day-to-day
stress so
yes it's a terrible period of time I get
it but we have to deal with it and when
you look at the reality of the situation
we are actually in a much better place
we're not home yet but we're in a better
place the really bad news would have
been if we concluded that we couldn't
control the spread of the virus that was
a possibility you looked at all those
initial project projections how do you
know that we we could control the spread
we could have done all those closed down
measures and it didn't work and the
spread continued that would have been
bad news
so relatively we're in a relatively good
place in downstate New York the curve is
on the Descent the question is now how
long is that descent is it a sudden
drop-off is it one week two weeks three
weeks six weeks we don't know but better
to be going down than to be going up
right let's keep that in mind and we are
going down how fast we'll find out but
we're in a better place
hospitalization numbers are coming down
intubation czar coming down number of
new people going into the hospital every
day is still troubling Lehigh but better
than it was but still problematic number
of lives lost is still breathtakingly
painful and the worst news that I have
to deliver every day and the worst news
that I've ever had to deal with as
governor of New York but at least it's
not going up anymore and it seems to be
on a gentle decline but make no mistake
this is a profound moment in history our
actions are going to shape our future
and you're not going to have to wait for
a 10-year analysis
this a retrospective to find out how our
actions affected our future what we do
today you will see the results in three
four or five days okay you tell me what
the people of this state in this country
do today you will see the results in the
number of hospitalizations in just a few
days we get reckless today there are a
lot of contacts today unprotected
contacts today you'll see that
hospitalization rate go up three four or
five days from today it is that simple
and it's that pressing that every
decision we make is going to affect how
we come out of this how fast we come out
of this so in this moment more than any
other truth not what you would like to
see what you hope to see not emotions
truth and facts truth and facts that's
how we operate here in the state of New
York truth and facts give me the truth
and give me the facts and that has to
guide our actions period we had a
productive meeting at the White House
yesterday productive visit so everybody
says productive visit very few people
come and say unproductive visit right
what does that mean productive visit to
me a productive visit means we spoke
truth we spoke facts we made the made
decisions and we have a plan going
forward and that was accomplished
yesterday and I feel good about it
personally because it's what should have
happened right the big issues on the
table in the political process well he
said this she said this and you get into
he said she said or you get into a blame
game finger-pointing but the meeting was
very productive and by the way these are
people in the White House who
politically don't like me
that's the fact right you see the
president's tweets he's often tweeted
very unkind things about me and my
brother politically he does not we've
had conflicts back and forth but we sat
with him we sat with his team and that
was put aside because who really cares
how I feel or how he feels who cares
get the job done I don't care if you
like him he likes you you know we're not
setting up possible marriage here just
do the job right when you're at war
you're in a foxhole nobody says well do
you like the person you're in the
foxhole with who cares you protect the
other person in the foxhole
then you get out of the foxhole and you
take the hill charge up the hill and
that's how we should be operating now I
don't care what your politics are I
don't care what you think about my
politics doesn't matter we both have a
job to do let's do the job and that was
the spirit of the meeting yesterday and
it was very productive on what were very
contentious unclear issues so it was
very good
the main issue was testing which I'll
talk more about in a second but we also
talked about state funding all the
governors are United Democrat and
Republican National Governors
Association every governor is saying the
same thing we have to have state funding
the states have a role basically in a
deficit situation and we need funding
from Washington they've passed bills
that help a lot of Americans that's
great help small businesses that's great
but you have to help state governments
because state governments fund the
people that the federal government can't
fund you know state and local
governments where funding police were
funding fire or funding teachers were
funding schools you can't just ignore
them and when you don't fund the states
then you're saying to the states well
you have to fund them and the states
have already said in one United choir we
we can't so we talked to the president
about that the president gets it the
president says he's going to work very
hard in the next piece of legislation
but you know I've been in Washington I
was there for eight years the Congress
has to insist that this is in the
legislation and yes they passed funding
for small businesses and funding for
testing and that's that's good that is a
good thing it's not a bad thing but it's
not enough either and they don't come
back every day with Congress it's hard
to get them to come back and this was
not the time for baby steps this is when
you should be taking bold action right
the action is proportionate to the issue
and you haven't had a problem that is
any bigger than this that any of those
senators or Congress people have ever
dealt with well then your action should
be proportionate and responsive to the
problem and it wasn't the president also
agreed which is a big deal for New York
to waive what's called the state match
for FEMA normally a state has to pay 25
percent of the FEMA cost that would be a
cruel irony for New York and adding
insult to injury
New York had the highest number of
coronavirus cases in the country
therefore our cost of FEMA was the
highest cost in the nation and therefore
New York should pay the highest amount
how ironically cruel would that be
you're going to penalize us for having
the highest number of coronavirus cases
in the country and at the same time that
Congress passed a piece of legislation
not even funding the states so the
president agreed to waive that and that
is a very big deal that's hundreds of
millions of dollars for the state of New
York but the the big issue was testing
and we've been talking about testing
tracing and then isolating
and that is going to be the key going
forward that's how you are educated and
have some data points as you're working
your way through this reopening
calibration right how does it work
you test the person if the person winds
up positive you then trace that person's
contacts contact Tracy you have to start
with a large number of tests and we said
as a goal yesterday to double the number
of state tests to go from 20,000 on
average to 40,000 that is just about the
maximum capacity for all of the
laboratory machines in this state okay
we have private labs about 300 of them
that we regulate they have purchased
machines over time these are very
expensive machines if you took every
machine we had and they had all the
supplies they needed from the national
manufacturers and you ran that machine
seven days a week 24 hours a day how
many tests could you do about 40,000 so
that's if you put your foot to the floor
you brought the engine up to maximum rpm
up to the redline you brought it up to
6,000 assuming the redline was 6,000 and
you held it there 7 days 24 hours a day
at redline how many tests could you do
40,000 now there's a lot of buts and ifs
in there but the machine has to stay
together for seven days 24 hours a day
you have to have enough people feeding
the machine but that is our maximum
potential so where did we set the goal
at our maximum potential why because we
need to well it's unrealistic might be a
little unrealistic but I'd rather set
the bar high and try to get there and
then whatever we get is what we get but
once you do all those tests every
positive you have to go back and trace
and the tracing is a very big big deal
what you trace and you find more
positives than you isolate the positives
they're under quarantine they can't go
out they can't infect anybody else this
entire operation has never been done
before
so it's intimidating you've never heard
the words testing tracing isolate before
no one has we've just never done this
for a few textbooks that spoke about it
but we've never done it and we've done
never done it anywhere near this scale
so it is an intimidating exercise but I
say so what who cares that you've never
done it that's really irrelevant it's
what we have to do now so figure out how
to do it what we have to put together a
tracing army yes okay we put together
armies before never a tracing army but
we can put together people we can
organize we can train and we can do it
and yes it's a big deal but it's what we
have to do and it's what we will do we
want to operate on a tri-state basis
I've spoken to governor Murphy in New
Jersey who's doing a great job and
governor Lamont in Connecticut is doing
a great job and who've been very great
neighbors to New York it's best to do
this tracing on a tri-state area why
because that's how our society works the
virus doesn't stop at jurisdictional
boundaries well I'm at the Town of
Brookhaven I stopped here no the virus
doesn't say that the virus just spreads
and you look at the spread pattern of
the virus it is in a metropolitan area
so we'll work together this is going to
be a massive undertaking good news is
Mayor Michael Bloomberg has volunteered
to help us develop and implement the
tracing program
Mayor Bloomberg was mayor of New York
City as you know three terms as governor
I worked with Mayor Bloomberg he has
then developed an organization he worked
with mayor's all across the world
literally and providing them guidance he
has tremendous insight both governmental
II and from a private sector business
perspective in this remember his company
Bloomberg they went through the China
closed down open up they went through
the European closed down open up so he's
had quite a bit of experience in this
area it's a very big undertaking and we
thank you very much for taking it on
because it is going to require a lot of
attention a lot of insight a lot of
experience and a lot of resources we're
also going to be partnering with Johns
Hopkins and vital strategies in putting
together that tracing operation
it'll be coordinated tri-state and
downstate why downstate because again
downstate operates as one area about 25%
30% of the workforce that goes into New
York City comes from outside of New York
City I have a house in Westchester I
work in New York City who's supposed to
trace me Westchester or New York City if
I turn up positive yeah my residence is
in Westchester County but I worked in
New York City and I would have contacted
many more people in New York City than I
did in Westchester because that's where
if I work in New York City that's where
I'm contacting people I live in Suffolk
but I work in New York City I'm a police
officer
who has a house in Rockland but I work
in New York City
I'm a firefighter who lives in Rockland
were orange but I work in New York City
I live in New Jersey but I worked in the
city I live in the city but I work in
Connecticut right
so all those interconnections if you're
going to do these tracing operations you
can't do it within just your own County
because you'll quickly run into people
who are cross-jurisdictional so
understand that going in blur the
governmental jurisdictions because they
don't really make sense put everybody
together work together harder done than
said but a hundred percent right there's
no doubt about that we're gonna take the
initial tracers that people have now the
state has about two hundred and twenty
five today Rockland is forty was just it
was fifteen now so sixteen New York City
two hundred they're going to work
together Mayor Bloomberg is known is
going to start with that core but we
have to build on that because we will
literally need thousands SUNY and CUNY
have thirty five thousand medical
students that we're going to we're going
to draw from but we have to put together
a significant operation because the
numbers get very big very quickly here
today is also the fiftieth anniversary
of Earth Day when you look at many of
the numbers that we're finding and you
look at the disparity between the
african-american community Latino
community that is a higher rate of
infection than people in the white
community start to ask why and you start
to study those health disparities you
also find that in those areas where the
corona virus infection rate is higher
they tend to be minority areas and by
the way those minority areas tend to be
the places where we cited plants that
pollute the asthma rates respiratory
illnesses are three times higher among
people in the african-american community
three times the asthma rate the
respiratory illness rate they're getting
more coronavirus there are higher
percentage of essential workers you see
how these two factors come together and
make a bad situation worse let's learn
from that
one of the lessons that we have to learn
and we have to go forward and we will
the positive messages look how well we
do when we actually focus and we make a
decision and we say we have to do this
if you had told me two months ago that I
would be able to stand up before the
people of the state and say by the way
we have to close down everything
business is closed everything closes
everybody going to the home close the
door lock it don't come out I would have
said it's not going to work it's not
going to work you're not going to get 19
million New Yorkers we're just a defiant
group of people questioning everything
they're not going to do it well maybe if
you give them all the facts and they
understand and they'll do it and we did
look at the potential look at the
possibility of what you can actually do
well then can you really make a real
difference on these issues that we've
been fighting for decades but we haven't
really made the progress we need to
climate change the environment yes you
can last last point my phone is ringing
I'm talking to many local officials they
feel political pressure to open I
understand I said yesterday that we're
going to make decisions based on a
regional basis because just as the
nation has different states and
different positions New York State has
different regions in different positions
north country is one set of facts facts
this is about truth and facts north
country has one set of facts Western New
York has a different set of facts
Capitol district has a different set of
facts make decisions based on the facts
and the facts are different in downstate
New York in many areas also make them on
the facts and realize the consequence of
what you could do opening one region but
not other regions and how you could
flood that one region and give them a
host of problems they never anticipated
but make the decision on the facts I get
it don't make the decision based on
political pressure I'm not going to do
that I am NOT going to do that this is a
profound moment we make a bad move it's
going to set us back and I get the
political pressure and I get the
political pressure that local officials
are under we can't make a bad decision I
get the pressure but we can't make a bad
decision
frankly this is no time to act stupidly
period I don't know how else to say it
and I've said it in numerable times to
local officials on the phone I get the
pressure I get the politics we can't
make a bad decision and we can't be
stupid about it this is not going to be
over anytime soon I know people want out
I get it I know people want to get back
to work
I know people need a paycheck I know
this is unsustainable I also know more
people will die if we are not smart I
know that I have to do that count
everyday of the number of people who
passed away we're not going to have
people lose their life because we acted
imprudently I'm not going to do that I'm
not going to do that and I'm not going
to allow the state to do it and I'm not
going to have the obituary of this
period be well they felt political
pressure so they got nervous and they
acted imprudently that's not who we are
so I've said to them look if you look at
any of the facts the 1918 flu they're
talking about it now this they can be
waves to this right you walk out into
the ocean you get hit with that first
wave oh great
I got I'm done the wave hit me I'm still
standing beware because there can be a
second wave or there could be a third
wave so don't be cocky just because you
got hit by a wave and it didn't knock
you off your feet there can be a second
wave and if you're not ready for the
second wave that's the wave that's going
to knock you
because you're not ready for so that's
what I'm worried about and also to the
local officials and local politicians I
have no problem with them blaming me
it's a very simple answer say to
everyone whatever they say I agree with
you it's the governor because by the way
it is the governor it is these are state
laws that are in effect the local
official can't do anything about them
anyway
because they can't contradict the state
law so it's true so the local official
can say it's the governor blame him it's
true and it will stop us from doing
something that's counterproductive and
it'll also stop us from getting into a
dispute between me and the local
government where the net message will be
to the people there's disagreement or
confusion among government and this is
not the time for confusion or
disagreement among government so the
state laws govern I get the local
political pressure blame the governor
it's the truth
and the state laws can't counter the
local laws can't counteract state laws
anyway and to this political pressure
this is a quote that I think people
should take to heart when the freedom
they wished for most was freedom from
responsibility then they ceased to be
free Edith Hamilton originally Edward
Gibbon in the history of the decline of
fall of the Roman Empire when the
freedom they wished for most was freedom
from responsibility then they ceased to
be free we have a responsibility today
to ourselves and to others
there is a codependency and a mutuality
among people in society that is more
clear and distinct than we have ever
seen it you sneeze I get sick you sneeze
I get sick it is that close a connection
you have a responsibility to act
prudently these are the other people
because you're not just putting your own
life at risk you're risking my life and
my children's life and my parents life
and you don't have that right
you have to act responsibly and to
advocate for total irresponsibility
let's all be irresponsible no not here
not now any questions let's we don't
need to speak over each other I will
answer your question so that each person
asked a question and then we're going to
next
talk to me specifically is Michael
Bloomberg providing funding are you
giving them the power to hire people and
mayor de Blasio this morning talked
about the city launching its own effort
to do tracing and testing how will the
two things overlap they will all be
coordinated city's effort will be
coordinated
Nasus effort Suffolk's effort
Westchester's effort they will be hiring
people independently you have city
employees that chart with the number of
employees those will be Westchester
employees that employee city employees
but it all has to be coordinated
there is no tracing that can work within
one jurisdiction
you cannot trace someone within the
boundaries of New York City because once
the person goes outside of New York City
well now that would be a Westchester
person right I live in Westchester take
me
lived in Westchester I worked in New
York City New York City's gonna trace me
how I'm in Westchester that's a
different County
you can't trace me well we'll go trace
people in Westchester
oh no no then what's justice gonna say
that's my resident don't come in here
and trace my resident
all right let's forget the
jurisdictional fight in the political
local fight will coordinate everyone
this is a monumental undertaking who's
gonna do it we're all going to do it
city stay Nassau Suffolk Jersey
Connecticut okay how do we do it I don't
know we've never done it before Michael
Bloomberg will design the program design
the training he's going to make a
financial contribution also put together
an organization that can help hire the
people because we have to expand this
number tenfold and get this all done
like this this has to happen you don't
have months to plan and do this you have
weeks to get this up and running super
ambitious undertaking and Mayor
Bloomberg will help coordinate the
entire effort he'll be working with the
state I'm working with the city and the
Nassau and Suffolk and Jersey and
Connecticut I don't know what the
financial contribution is anybody knows
but what Mayor Bloomberg is doing is
through the program at Johns Hopkins
which he funds very heavily their public
health program which is preeminent in
the country he's helping us to design
the programmatic operational and
technological components of our contract
tracing program and the in partnership
with us are creating an online
curriculum to train the tracers to
recruit them to interview to perform the
background checks and then we're going
to coordinate all of the counties and
also with New Jersey and Connecticut
[Music]
are you planning on contact tracing that
cohort as well according people that
have already been diagnosed you will
trace as many positives as you can and
as the testing number goes up that
number of possible people to be traced
is going up the implication of your
question is right
won't you be identifying more positive
people than you could possibly ever
trace yes I believe that's true I don't
care how big an army you put together
you now have let's say take your number
250,000 people tested positive how do
you start to trace 250,000 people how
many people do you need to trace 250,000
people that's why it's an
extraordinarily impossible task and you
do the best you can contact tracing life
is options going forward how do you
educate yourself and reopen it well we
need data where does the data come from
the data comes from testing now you have
a hard database of hospitalizations you
can look at the hospitalizations and
they will tell you how many people got
sick enough to go into the hospital
that's all it tells you you don't know
how many people were infected you don't
know what is happening on the infection
rate spread all you know is the
hospitalization rate so testing will
give you first of all more data on how
fast the infection is spreading and how
fast it's spreading where you're gonna
get a very different number in New York
City than you get in Buffalo then you
get in the north country then you get an
opening okay that'll inform the regional
reopening and then what you're trying to
do to the extent possible the whole
concept of testing ISIL testing tracing
isolate
not just here but every state is talking
about this to the extent you can when
you find a positive person trace it back
and isolate well if you wind up with a
population let's say we wind up with a
10% infection rate in the state or in
the city that's you know a million
people in New York City infected how
could you possibly trace a million
people you can't you do the best you can
but for every person you isolate Jesse
that's one less person walking around
infecting another than people like how
much money could this possibly cost well
if it was 50 60 percent you'd be at a
different issue point if you were at 50
60 then you would be arguing what they
called herd immunity that would be don't
do any of this that's sort of Sweden and
like Brazil just let it go and whoever
gets infected gets infected whoever dies
dies and at one point everybody a
critical mass of the population is
infected and then whatever happens
happens it's not gonna be 50 60 and that
that strategy some countries have
adopted a lot of people die with that
strategy which is a downside but it's
not going to be 50 60 my guess is it's
going to be 10 percent about now in the
high infection areas it's a guess but I
would guess 10 percent downstate single
digits upstate
[Music]
[Music]
you're right dr. Zucker is in a better
position to answer so on the question
about the Sarah we are working on this
there have been patients who have
received this from within some of our
hospital systems the data was still
waiting to hear about the clinical
results from that so that's moving
forward the more people that we have
that end up positive and recover the
more Sarah will be available the more
information we'll have on that part on
the monoclonal antibodies so this
Regeneron corporation here in new york
state has been looking at this issue and
we've been speaking with them there is a
day to suggest that the use of
monoclonal antibodies may be beneficial
based on how the monoclonal antibodies
have been used for other conditions
where they end up with the same kind of
response where the where they're what's
called cytokine storm where their lungs
are damaged as a result of infection so
there may be a relationship here and
we're working closely with them on that
I mean it was traumatic and that was
part of it that's my advice
well the aisle six receptor antibodies
there's two different companies that
have been working on it and that has
been given to patients across the state
who have this and already and the
monoclonal antibody there's a specific
therapy for that that's also in not
really experimental but has been
provided to those who are ill moving
that upstate to also do tracing and also
you said there was gonna be announcement
with nursing home inspections possibly
today we're gonna make the nursing home
announcement tomorrow it's in the works
though we wanted to talk about this
today what was first part of a tracing
is going to be done statewide and
testing has to be done statewide testing
does two things for you remember the
rate of viral infection spread so you
have a calibration on the reopening and
second on the antibody testing one of
the upsides is you find people who have
the antibody so they can contribute for
the convalescent plasma by donating
their blood Joseph
when you say my opinion when you say
you're not going to open schools you may
as well say you're not going to open
businesses because the two were
connected I don't know how you really
open businesses without opening schools
you want me to go to work
hallelujah what do I do with my kids so
the two to me are very connected the
school year is up in June to say we're
not going to open businesses until June
I'm not there yet I don't think people
are there yet this is a situation that
changes week to week so let's get the
information week to week let's get the
data and then we'll make a determination
plus we're trying to coordinate with
Jersey Connecticut other states so let's
get the data in the meantime schools
will not open until we say schools will
open statewide period new paragraph
opening schools is very difficult I
would not open a school unless we knew
that the schools were disinfected that
they had a protocol going forward to
disinfect the schools that they had a
protocol where there was going to be a
certain amount of social distancing and
protective personal behavior in the
school that is a very very big
undertaking job theoretically could you
yes could you say North Country schools
are going to open with all those
provisos yes you could say that you
could say you can open North Country
schools having nothing to do with Nassau
schools and Westchester schools yes the
total totally disconnected and you could
argue that you could make those as
isolated decisions yes yes sir yeah
because once you say we're moving
towards reopening one of the first
integral pieces is business in school
and then transportation right you need
those three gears to turn at the same
time you can't turn the business gear
which is intermeshed with the school
gear which is intermeshed with the
public transportation gear you turn one
gear you have to turn all three gears
turn few days a few days how do you know
who's taking place in grocery stores did
they ask you I can't tell if you're
smiling on behind the mask we're taking
surveys random surveys all across the
state
literally grocery stores street corners
just to get random samples of people to
take an antibody test it's going to be
the largest study done in the country to
find out what basically how many people
have been infected Jesse said maybe 50
60 percent of the population that would
take you to one place if it's five ten
percent it would take you to another
place what is it what percent of the
population has been affected nobody
knows nobody knows I think this I think
this I think this yeah it's nice what
you think what's the fact nobody knows
the fact Bernadette is the state doing
to help nursing homes comply with that
executive order saying that patients or
patients cannot be denied readmission or
admission to nursing homes because I've
spoken to several different sources in
that field who have said it's difficult
for to keep staffing levels high and
also separate the co-ed from the
non-covered patients so what is the
state doing to assist with those
facilities and then also Plan B if these
facilities don't have enough space to
separate those patients so two parts
that one is the issue of what we're
doing as I had mentioned once before we
are working very closely with the
leadership in the nursing homes both to
get more staff to help them out
obviously the supplies were working very
hard on that we're also looking at how
they could help cohort patients a little
bit better so that those who are
positive or our cohort within the
nursing home to to address that and the
second person we're looking at that as
well you have to remember that one of
the challenges a little bit with with
the nursing home patients those who
really elderly you take them out of
their environments it's very disruptive
so we're trying to work to balance both
maintain the environment that they're
comfortable with but also provide their
safety on the standpoint Public Health
and just general safety let's just let's
just flip the equation for a second okay
the state doesn't run a nursing home
your questions sound like it the state
runs the nursing home the state does not
run the nursing home it is run by the a
private corporation the Acme corporation
said you should bring your mother to the
Acme corporation it's the best nursing
home in the world and they get paid for
that service the state regulates the
nursing home but it's a private
corporation and those are not-for-profit
but basically the same thing
that gets paid for their service and
they're supposed to provide that service
that's what they do they take care of
senior people people with illnesses etc
that's what they get paid to do we set a
regulatory framework for them to do it
if they can't do it they should say I
can't do it I can't take care of your
mother don't pay me I can't think of
your mother I don't have this space I
don't have the staff I can't take care
of your mother and then
we'll help you find another facility for
your mother
there are a lot of beds in nursing home
so we could find another nursing home
for you but they have to do the job
they're getting paid to do and if
they're not doing the job they're
getting paid to do and they're violating
state and regulations then that's a
different issue and they should lose
their license that's how this
relationship works the state is not
going to come in and do their job for
them that would be a state-run facility
that's a prison that's you know a
different situation where we run the
facility we don't run these facilities
it's their patient it's their patient
and their patient that they're getting
paid to take care of now contracts the
culprit virus okay now you have to take
care of that patient who you're getting
paid to take care of with the Cova virus
if you can't yeah if you can't if you're
saying I can't take care of my patients
then fine then tell us you can't take
care of the patients and we'll make
other we'll make other accommodations
well if you can't run your business you
can't run your business penalty is your
own you know you're out of business if
you are not providing adequate care for
your patients then you're violating your
license look if they say any nursing
home that calls up and says I can't do
this we'll make other accommodations
no no timeline I neither the tracing
will start it's actually starting now
but it has to be brought to a level that
nobody even imagined before so that's
going to be an iterative incremental
process right you're starting now with
what you have we have about 500 tracers
now but build on that hire more staff
more training how do you do this cross
jurisdictional tracing which doesn't
happen now the tracers have been in the
old framework of I do my city I do my
County so this is going to be all new
and we'll be ramping up so tracing is
going on tracing will be ramping up
incrementally going forward when do you
stop ramping up maybe never on the
40,000 testing same thing testing is
going on now we're doing more testing
than any state in the United States more
testing per capita than any country on
the globe so we're doing a phenomenal
amount of tests and we've ramped up
faster than anybody else and we'll
continue to ramp up let's just do
everybody was good I don't know if you
can hear but there are protesters
outside right now talking their horns
and raising signs we did speak to a few
of them before we came in and these are
regular people who are not getting a
paycheck some of them are not getting
their unemployment check and they're
saying that they don't have time to wait
for all of this testing and they need to
get back to work in order to feed their
families their savings is running out
they don't have another week they're not
getting answers so their point is that
cure can't be worse than the illnesses
what is your response to that the
illness is death
what is worse than death somebody
commits suicide because they can't pay
their yeah but the illnesses maybe my
death
as opposed to your death you said they
said the cure is worse than the illness
the illness is death how can the Cure be
worse than the illness if the illness is
potential death what if the economy
failing worse than death is those people
stuck at home no it doesn't it doesn't
equal death economic hardship yes very
bad not death emotional stress from
being locked in a house very bad not
death domestic violence on the increase
very bad not death and not death of
someone else see that's what we have to
factor into this equation yeah it's your
life do whatever you want but you're not
responsible for my life you have a
responsibility to me it's not just about
you your responsibility to me right we
started here saying it's not about me
it's about we get your head about the
around the we concept so it's not all
about you it's about me too
it's about we also I get the economic
hardship everybody gets it everybody
feels it federal government is sending
out a check for individuals $600 an
additional $1,200
we are moving heaven and earth to get
the unemployment payments going so we
get the economic anxiety the question is
how do you respond to it and do you
respond to it in a way that jeopardizes
Public Health
and possibly causes more people to die
and think about it as if it was your
family that might get infected right and
that's what we're talking about and when
you think about it is your family you
have a different perspective I'll tell
you the truth it's not an abstract
argument what they say he says she says
he says she says I know that's how it
works
well the protesters say this governor
says this to say this governance is this
okay think about it as your family might
be in the mix because when I see 484 New
Yorkers dying I feel that it's like
people in my family and nothing comes
before the public health risk of
somebody else's life and that's where we
are but they're also saying if you can't
afford to pay me unemployment or you or
your system you will be paid you will be
paid yeah we're talking about a couple
of days lag on the unemployment
insurance and they will get the check
from the date of an employment does that
cost them an extra penny now they can
say unemployment insurance isn't enough
I get it even with a six hundred dollar
check and the twelve hundred dollar
check and the unemployment insurance
benefit is not enough I understand the
economic hardship we all feel it the
question is what do you do about it
and do you put public health at risk and
do you drive up the number of deaths for
it because you have no idea how to
reopen now saying that is there a
fundamental right to work if the
government can't get me the money when I
need it you want to go to work go take
the job as an essential worker do it
tomorrow right you're working you're an
essential worker so go take the job is
it essential
but people are hiring because there were
people hiring you can get a job as an
essential worker so now you can go to
work and you can be an essential worker
and you're not gonna kill anyone there's
1.3 billion dollars available from the
federal government for Tracy 1.3 billion
dollars available from the federal
government which will help fund Tracy
for New York yes we are hearing reports
that many of the nursing home staff are
not getting the proper PPE and so the
question is the ownership of the nursing
facility no no they're not a state-run
entity that's what I'm trying to say I
know there's a thought a nursing home is
run by the state it's a wrong thought
you know facts the private entity runs
it we regulate the private entity if the
entity private entity is not performing
their duty as they should be then the
state takes action versus the private
entity you can lose your license you'll
be out of business if you're not
providing your staff with the right
equipment you're out of business
that we can do see for the state the
question should be we have been helping
them with more PPE but again it's not
our job the question would be why don't
we put that nursing home out of business
which is a fair question to the state
and if we have a nursing home that is
violating and that's part of what we're
going to talk about tomorrow then they
should lose their license they can't do
their jobs to those you can't be the
hospital's yeah let's do persons
putting their sick into nursing homes
but also what about the people whose
family members are not safe like what if
my grandma's in a nursing home she's
healthy but she's old
she might have a pre-existing condition
and the same facility that she's living
in is now accepting Kovac patients and
the facility doesn't have the capacity
to separate the two it is a there is no
state policy on yeah but if if the
question is should I put my mother in a
nursing home anyone who has read any of
the FAQs or any newspaper article has to
appreciate that this virus attacks
people in nursing homes it is ground
zero our introduction was in Seattle in
a nursing home the nursing homes are the
top top location with this predator
feeds it is puts together vulnerable
people in one location right when the
lion is going across the plain looking
for prey here's the prey vulnerable
people in one place under one roof
that's where the predator will attack
and has attacked and will continue to
attack and the predator is insidious and
very good at what it does and we've
tried everything to keep it out of a
nursing home but it's virtually
impossible I believe we can reduce the
rate of infection on nursing homes but
once it gets in it is vicious that is a
fact
so if somebody says to me should I put
my mother in a nursing home now now is
not the best time to put your mother in
a nursing home that is a fact
someone who watched before we we're
gonna have to hire many many more
tracers
the capacity is going to have to is
going to have to expand it will be
concentrated down state because it's
with the concentration of cases are but
it will also be employed in upstate New
York will have it is will be a statewide
again coordinated on a tri-state basis
but it will be proportionate to where
the cases are and when we see a cluster
and an outbreak quote-unquote hotspot
then one of the strategies is send
testers tracers isolate that's how you
reduce the spread in that hotspot let's
do one more somebody who has whatever we
have we distribute and then we ask the
federal government for assistance
they've been sending us what they have
and what they can get but one of the
lessons learned from this is as soon as
we get our our head above water this is
madness that we have to buy gowns and
masks from China and we're wholly
dependent on China for masks gowns
gloves ventilators everything came back
to China that all has to change and look
it's an opportunity for this state other
states to but we have to be able to make
this equipment right here and be able to
turn up the volume when something like
this happens this is it's been ready for
the board we can't get masks can't get
gowns can't get ventilators vials
reagents the entire supply chain has to
be brought back to this country period
I'm n you in the back I'm sorry
do we anybody test asymptomatic people
yes it's a random sample I'm sorry
I should have known that is it it
doesn't do symptomatic asymptomatic if
Karen was in a grocery store and anybody
who walks up to the counter they will
test so it's not symptomatic
asymptomatic that's rent oh if you were
symptomatic you don't get the antibody
test cost of what what's the updated Oh
spend to date on Kovac it's
approximately 2.8 billion dollars about
half of that is in New York City
tracing programs cause I don't know
whatever I don't know the federal
government has provided money in this
past budget but whatever it cost a cost
you know what's the value of a life
Jessa
when they go out in the world and they
come back in ten the regulation the
health department you know can the
decent regulation to ensure that the
nursing homes are doing better in terms
of whether taking a temperature of doing
something with staff to make sure that
they don't bring this into this we have
done regulations on that and we'll have
more to say on that tomorrow I don't
want to give away tomorrow's Minister's
then you won't come thank you guys